ah
Kyrie Irving crossover college who's a
nas from the crowd
Kyrie Irving what a handle Kyrie Irving
was behind his back Knights through two
men including Devon too big step puts it
hard off the window it is I wreaths were
bikini anywhere he walks on the floor
Irving who's a nod from the crowd in
Irving with the finish his handle is
amazing sometimes mad how quickly he can
change directions and start stop what a
show put on Kyrie Irving the real
razzle-dazzle
way to go sis Biagio me he lost Kyrie
Irving Dan Turnham young fella dance on
him in the to carry all 20 go bruising
ankles and he goes as he goes to the
we went to the basket
- good
[Applause]
always
serving on the right side is bothered by
rightly guided
got rid of rice gonna double down the
lawyer to Victor Rowland and I fooled by
Kyrie Irving is tied this deep it's down
to three Kyrie Irving do it
[Music]
Oh
Kairi masterful inside all the greatest
a great deep is which it was by malcolm
brogdon how did Kyrie get out of that
double team blue is it a straitjacket
and freed himself I wouldn't want to
defend himself whose eyes from the crowd
manages to get the ball back putting on
a show of the ball
Mervin ridiculous handle dribbles behind
his back he loses it but chase it down
near the sideline
Kyrie oohs and ahs tempat Lopes and
scores off the window
wonderful beautiful mover
[Applause]
Oh handling in this league look at her
Winnie Falls up oh you're not close
enough sorry young boys I'm gonna have
to knock this down what up at you boy
Adam left go do you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report